are you kidding me ouch wow that one's
really good
i need your help i need you to roast me
in fact i would like all of social media
to roast me
it's been four days since posting that
exact video to
all of my social media accounts and i
posted that video along with some
pictures
[Music]
[Applause]
my guess is as good as yours in terms of
how are people possibly going to make
fun of these i swear i haven't seen any
of these i really have been off social
media the past couple days what you're
about to hear are the real replies real
comments real direct messages that i got
sent well i am the one being roasted i'm
also going to be judging the quality of
these roasts on things like originality
creativity and overall ouch factor
and lastly for the roasts that really
just knock my socks off the roasts that
wow me the roasts that make me want to
call my mommy we will be pushing
the big time squirts button here we go
[Applause]
read me the first roast are you sure
you're ready
no chris you're 6 11 and you weigh 90
pounds
gumpy it's a better body than you
that's decent throughout this video
there's probably going to be a lot of
stuff about my body which is to be
expected
i'm long and a narrow boy uh
what do you want me to do i am
comfortable in my body that's why i'm
that's why give me these roasts i wonder
when the internet was created they
planned for your awful content
that's really good if this is what you
want to call content for the internet
that's a big time scourge all right next
who gave slender man a makeover oh that
one's really good too
ouch little ouch spice on that one nice
roast
you look like the lanky offspring of
hermann munster and groucho marx
spit a little there good mustache burn
these are good beanstalker vibes beats
stalker vibes
what is a beanstalker might be making my
twitter handle beanstalker
good roast you look like a papa's one
durian customizable character with those
letters
no no no no no no no re-roasts
this roast in particular is referring to
one of my favorite youtube comments
arguably it inspired this video i don't
play a lot of video games but i know
what it means in video games to put
all the sliders to max that burn is
rejected it's a recycle
does not count you look like vermicelli
noodles with facial hair
with one hair facial hair
vermicelli i don't know but i know what
it means
oh my god i am getting destroyed
if you didn't have arms and were pink
you would actually be a flamingo
very good that one's creative that one's
original
not quite enough for a big time scorch
but appreciated
would you be considered an influencer if
you influenced me to shave my mustache
oh whoa that one is really good
that is a big time scorch
your face and body make everyone
uncomfortable
okay uh the simplicity of that one is
really resonating with me
your bones are showing
i don't like that one at all you look
racist
what is that mean look at a couple likes
too
consensus in the comments don't
love that good burn i can't roast you i
love you too much
sorry that's my grandmother if we can
all take a little page out of
gammy's book when you bone your wife
it's literal
guys excuse me
you leave my wife out of this really
good roast your lungs stuck and you're
wearing bridget's pants and picture one
boom roasted when i was a senior in high
school
my lung collapsed when i was five years
old and you were my camp counselor i
told my mom that you looked like a stick
figure multiple times
oh that is deeply entrenched in my my
professional past as a
harmless camp counselor really good one
that's
that's the big time scorch my
great-aunt's party shirt
has never looked less festive i knew
someone was gonna come for this shirt
very original very specific i appreciate
the reference to the picture
it had shoulder pads don't bro your
eyebrows go above your eyes not on your
lip
i just went up to defend my mustache
big time scorch i am so happy that
someone came for my eyebrows or
lacked thereof
any time my wife can't even speak
without laughing i know it's gonna be a
zinger you suck at crash bandicoot and
your weird grinch stuff makes me
hesitant for you to be around my
daughter
here's the thing i gave you guys a
couple pictures
to make fun of and everyone is digging
in
what else i post online nice burn oh
he thinks people care
why you gotta take to socials for
humiliation wife won't cook you
not enough money for a dominatrix sure
had enough dough for the j crew fall
line
i mean seriously what's going so wrong
in your little norm core life that you
need this to feel
something just do drugs like the rest of
us nice watch though
excellent burn big time scorch
thank you to everyone who roasted me i
really appreciate it i am happy with the
way i look
i am happy with the way i dress and i'm
happy
with my mustache okay
and i love my sweet beautiful wife
and if any of you ever say anything
about my wife in a roast call out again
so help me god